The jogan Experience speaking of Native
American you see that chock talk kid
this the uh the Chiefs the Kansas City
Chiefs kid was crazy crazy was the what
was the newspaper that they from the
they they totally [__] hosed him
totally hosed him they said he was in
black face and they showed a picture of
one side of his face he was wearing war
paint Native American I love that oh and
it was a just a Chiefs game where it's
like it's a to get racially sensitive at
a [__] Kansas City Chiefs SK you're
at the wrong place an entire Stadium of
white people's
going you going to pick the one kid I
know it's so crazy to put up a kid's
picture child and get it wrong not just
get it wrong get it wrong and know
you're getting it wrong and then he
doubled down when he was wrong he
was on Monday the leftwing publication
dead spin alleged that the football fan
identify as Holden arm
found a way to hate black people and the
Native Americans at the same time that's
not easy imagine that why why is it hate
though why do we go right to hate that's
the bummer look at that hateful
[__] what a hate what a hate
Monger he probably loves pizza so what
is his background he has uh some Native
American background oh he owns a casino
his background is he loves football like
a real American true yeah he's part of
native aor so it says his child's
father's a son of Raul armenta a
business Committee Member of the Santa
YZ Board of Chumash Indians oh Jesus
he's deep he's a real Native American so
funny they're like you must be hateful
it's like wait can I just be native
americ God so this [__] kid is
literally dressing like his ancestors
wow and they're calling it he's hating
black people and bro they're getting
paid for this
one Indian giver I would love to see
these Publications how many positive
Giver didn't sneak by me I was just
liting my
cigar that a good
one I had to do a casino in Oklahoma
this week mhm the chief showed up CP
braging the chief showed up and said oh
no with his headress other people sat in
the front dude you're blocking everybody
[__] bombed did you get panicky cuz
he was there yeah right before I go on
stage the guy who runs the production
there goes hey just so you know the
chief's here this is the first time he's
seen a show in like 10 years they wanted
to come to see this oh my God they have
no [__] idea who I am your jokes
about Donald why would you think they
don't have any idea who you are they
live in America no but they definitely I
don't think he's like a seven-year-old
[__] Chief from yeah he's probably
online some funny Tik to he has good
Trump this guy is good Trump trump Down
syndrome syndrome with down there was a
comic in the 70s who was Native American
who would go tonight Jo go Hi how are
you Hi how are you yeah it's so nice
Charlie Hill Charlie Hill was a good
dude is he still around or he died he
Charlie Hill was cool he was a cool guy
Hill was nice he was always ni always
friendly man always cool to hang out
with at the store well they nice people
and that guy was around from like the
70s right he was in the early the prior
days early boom you had to have an act
you had to have a specific thing right
you had to be like this is who I am it
was like early WWF that good whiske
that's
hilarious